foreign
good morning good afternoon good evening
good everything everybody I am Gary
vaynerchuk founder and creator of the
friends and I'm super excited to be with
all of you a little bit of a salty mood
because of the Jets lost so my energy
might be a little bit low I'm here with
rips
rip say Hello Hello everybody welcome
thanks for joining are we gonna see your
face at all or is it going to be all
camera down
you can see my my peace sign those are
very nice fingers
big shout out to Danny Meadows uh Teresa
oh Dan Church in the building Kylie
breener uh we are here to do a v friends
box opening for our International
Friends uh rips why don't you give
everybody the uh history of how we got
here because we owed a little favorite
of the international friends for
everybody's joining that doesn't know
about V Brands it's my NFP project which
is also an intellectual property project
which is why we have toys and and videos
and um and collectibles and hear trading
cards rips how expensive is this box on
eBay right now for example yeah so these
boxes released in March um via zero cool
which is the new Fanatics trading card
company based around culture global
leaders influencers Brands Etc and not
basically non-sports trading cards
um be friends was their first ever
inaugural release
um and they launched only three domestic
customers and so they sold out
um 800 boxes were sold out of the
Thousand made total 800 sold for two
thousand one hundred fifty dollars a
piece
um resale right now is about four to
five grand four four to five thousand
dollars per box
um and because uh International
customers couldn't participate in the
initial auction this is the fun way to
allow them to participate and win some
cool cards because there are some really
really really big cards and probably
inarguably the best physical way to
collect be friends
and so what we're doing is we're taking
30 people from our International
Community and and rips how did those 30
people get selected yep so we for we
opened up a uh a page in which
um
I mean what cycle did I share here
friends opened up a Shopify page that
was available only to International
um attendees or International entrants
where
um they could basically just enter with
their name and international address to
win a spot so we have all of the
entrants here there's well over a
thousand
um and what we're going to do is
randomize this entire sheet five times
the 30 people on the top so there's 10
cards in each box we're doing three
boxes here
um the 10 spots or the 30 spots that are
on the top of this list will each get a
card from the Box in order so the first
card I open from this we'll go to slot
number one the second card will go to
slot number two until we're all done all
right so we're gonna randomize this
sheet that has a thousand plus uh V
friends uh people and uh uh let's
randomize
we're gonna do it five times because I
love the number five so here we go
number one
okay
number two
number three
number four don't do it yet all right
number four here we go this will be it
don't do it yet
and the first 30 people here will get
the third first 30 cards in order uh
rips uh actually let's do it boom
boom
there we go so we've got 30. it's gonna
go in this order Matthew Raymond Eugene
Joshua Azar Zhang and if I keep going
all the way down and we'll do this live
I'll do this live as well but the 30
ends at one down here order number eight
two two eight
um and actually sometimes in these boxes
you'll see 11 cards so there could be it
could go down to 31 and tell him down
here gets gets lucky
um
I'll focus into the first two lines
actually uh
are you sure that you went I think you
went a little long there isn't that it
doesn't start with number three
I've got 30. some it's filtered out a
little bit on the left so it doesn't go
exactly uh I see very nice maybe thank
you all right it says 30 on the bottom
right down here well let's give
congratulations if you see your name and
you're in the comments please say what's
up and say you're happy let me do this
in the Discord
did anyone win all right here we go
here we go remember and I can say the
name and order number as we kind of
unveil each card
great so now we're going to go into the
cards and uh and pull them now again go
ahead rips to your thing rips how much
is how much is a basic
Raw base card
um
about 200 bucks a piece got it it's
significant
yeah no and that's even without being
graded correct
the other thing is that there's all
there's only a thousand of these made
and so every time we open one of these
boxes it gets lower and then people play
into that like sealed wax
how do you think about that type of
stuff manual asked how do I get in the
list that was already done please if
you're not part of our Discord on
v-friendsgaryvee.com Discord garyvee.com
uh can you add garyvee.com Discord here
um Dustin on the bottom so people that
are watching who don't know about the
v-friends Discord and who want to be
part of this in the future can join
but to clarify before I open these this
is the front of the box so the first
card that comes out on the front here is
card number one the last card will be
card number 10 and we'll keep going so
this first card is going to Matthew
eighth number 8480 on the order number
Matthew congratulations
humble hummingbird
nice zoom in yes very nice that's a
chord that's not a rare one the white
ones are the core out of 20 right yeah
there's in each box there's at least one
one of one we're chasing autographs
Gary's been witness to two sketch cards
that have been pulled out of this we
haven't seen a single black hat one of
one Gary before we open the three is
there is there a weird garyvee
prediction of a one of one we might see
in these three boxes I think we're gonna
see very very very lucky black cat today
but I don't know if it's gonna be a one
of one but I'm wearing the hat and I
that's what I want all right let's do it
this first card's from Matthew next card
for e-ray
there the polar bear one of the clean
simple drawings I love it
number three for Raymond
loyal Lobster I love it nice job Raymond
nice little loyal Lobster we're gonna
start getting into the rare cards now I
think
Eugene at slot number four actually
we've done two cards so we are not doing
any right this one here is for Raymond
number four for Eugene rare five of
eight chill chinchilla
chill chinchilla with some autographs on
it five out of eight that one's a upper
little play there we're gonna get more
rare as we go on let's keep it going for
Joshua number five we know that one
you're gonna die fly I love it
one of the rare one of the few sketches
sold at Christie's that's right out of
eight very nice
oh epic jet screen
Jet's green two of two
shrimp I love it a lot of people are
asking what's going on we are we are
opening up a box of zero cool V friends
these are very limited edition cards you
can go to eBay and type in V friends to
see what's going on we're doing a box
opening for people that have won uh free
cards from our International Community
on our Discord if you want to learn more
garyvee.com Discord let's keep it going
this is the intellectual property that
I'm building my Pokemon my Marvel my uh
my Snoopy uh and so having a lot of fun
building out this brand and this is part
of it great this one was for Azar and
next we have more than one so wait who's
this for this is a one of one to who
this is going to our friend Zhang 80
order number 8274. love it John
congratulations
this is a big one no matter what it is
I love it the clever crocodile Diamond
one of one huge hit for all the V
friends holders in all the Chats on
Facebook uh YouTube uh LinkedIn I see
all of you talking please help people
understand what uh what what a little
bit about it it's a bit that's a big hit
as you can see by the comments wow
nice so every box is going to end with
some chorus sometimes we get two
one-on-ones but random with some chords
here okay suffocate
suffocate hate core I believe in this
the most that's for Alessandro next hit
for Christiane
a lot of it
The Logical lion
is for cold
and he's getting the oh nice one the
offense oriented orangutan the double
triple o all right while rips is setting
up the next box can we show on the
screen again the order of people just
want to make sure everybody there it is
as you can see we had a thousand people
enter from our Discord
um is that how that's where the
announcement was on our blog and our
Discord right reps correct great uh so
everybody's joining because I share this
on my channels this was going to be only
on V friends channels but I decided to
share it on my channels because I miss a
lot of you wanted to say what's up hope
everybody's having a good uh Halloween
happy Halloween uh we're doing a box
opening of V friends these are about
four thousand dollars a box on eBay
we're doing some break for our
International Friends on Discord because
they were unable to buy it I said that I
would do something here's what I'm doing
I'm opening three of these boxes and
giving away one card free to 30
different people uh and we're having a
lot of fun with this just enjoying our
day these cards are quite rare
um quite sought after it for the people
that are in the v friends world and
obviously hopefully as I continue to
build this intellectual property we'll
continue to have more and more demand
thank you for joining hope everybody's
super well happy happy happy Halloween
all right reps let's go to lot 11.
this first card I believe is for Matt
8576 order number right off the top the
Narwhal
I don't know our wall just
sorry I'm just texting in the uh
in the uh in the Discord all right
narwhals real nice one let's keep it
going Lydia
polished who's the most polished person
you know please uh please put it in the
comments right now for everybody's
watching thanks for joining I'm really
Lizzy V Verge great to see you Brunello
16 good to see you Angela Garcia let's
keep it going rips
the Admiral strikes rare
that's right this one is for Eva here
we're going down to g-u-e-y gooey sorry
about that but let's hope to get you a
good card oh a little ape a big one
that's a big one that's very sought
after in our world that's definitely
gonna get some attention from people in
the Discord who have gooey why uh you're
gonna definitely get hit up for that
let's keep it going who's next starter
jacket just came out next up a very rare
okay
for Caitlyn
nice job Caitlin
next hit or another epic these are hard
to find because there's only two per
character
oh the Rhino shout out cam I love it
okay okay we're in good shape okay that
was scary
all right reflector is an important
trait great job on the Rhino it should
be a one of one next here we go
bubblegum who's next this is a big one
bubblegum for demo I believe
demo
ooh the Bulldog love it the badass
Bulldog bubblegum one of one looks nice
shape too that's gonna be a real winner
Big shout out big win
X Card up oh another oh we got it Sonata
we got him all right so everybody this
is our first autograph
rips how much
of a minimum of about three to four
thousand all right so this is a three to
four thousand dollar collectible card
who's getting it who was the big winner
and someone said Andrew order number
7504 so when Andrew if you're in Discord
and you're in Andrew
you're in it here we go this is cute
oh love it
oh the crane excuse me the Curious crane
one of one Auto big hit
big hit big one look at that card
but this next card's even bigger it's a
metallic
like this is a dark horse character pea
salad has become like a meme inside of
be friends it it's a really fun crew of
characters it's like a Justice League
the pea salad cute root I love it all
right peace salad congratulations
whoever got that this last card is for
Christian
the psalm
back to my old world all right awesome
all right we got one final box
one final box
Gary the uh
the V Friends Community is taken onto
sports trading cards very well yes
people love them allowing a lot of
people to interact with the brand
physically does it surprise you what
what excites you the most about that and
I guess you've been doing trading cards
since you were very young what does it
mean this is yeah this is the most
emotional thing for me I mean go into
eBay and looking up be friends right now
and everybody should do that if you want
to learn about these cards there's two
different series series one series two
um this was series one like
the just watching like the sports car
community and there's a lot of cynicism
in the sports card Community there's a
lot of cynicism overall because the nft
world is in the same place the internet
world's in 99 where after the Internet
stock crash everyone's like oh see the
internet was a fad same thing with nfts
like I said last summer 99 were going to
zero but the one percent the Amazons the
paypals the ebays of this generation
were going to be meaningful and I'm
trying to do that with be friends and
sports cards is a great way to and trick
excuse me trading cards is a great way
to expand the intellectual property and
so this has been a huge I mean execution
this I mean the demand on these cards is
Monumental the eBay numbers are wild I'm
very humbled and I'm so happy for our
International friends who are getting
free ones here today just by being part
of our Discord everybody's watching
please join the Discord right now as a
matter of fact if you joined Discord
right now and you're new please say I'm
new because I'm in the Discord and I
want to say hello but more importantly
the community there is so nice that if
you say you're new you'll make a lot of
new friends tell people where you're
from make some real life friends the
community's been insane let's get to the
last box
okay
we're on our third box
you got 20 cards total 10 cards to go so
this first card coming out is going to
go to
Parham p-a-r-h-a-m order number 7788 our
final box here we go
first part out
oh the civet
here we go
come on black cat I made a prediction
come through going out to Varun on the
next card
gifted gopher
gifted gopher
oh don't say you're new in here in the
chat everyone go to garyvee.com Discord
join the discard and then say you're new
that's what I meant
here we go Danny Meadow is always top
ten next card is for Matthew here
oh driven Dragon rare that's a nice hit
we got rares of the last two big merch
collabs yeah driven dragon is a beast
right alert ape and driven Dragon the
last two the starter jacket and the
hoodie uh do we have any starter jackets
left
we do good let's put up that up here can
the team put a garyvee.com starter URL
so we could put it up here and team can
get the last couple because I know it's
less than a couple dozen all right let's
keep it going
next card up
another rare
generous verbal he's giving away those
money bags he's generous
shop.bfriends.com we can put that up
there people can find it easy that way
and see the other stuff they are they
are pricey block and especially with the
recession do not spend money you can't
afford to lose I know you need the Jack
and I think it's cool I see in the
comments but do not buy it if you can't
afford it all right
order 76ers
very rare
who was born in 1997. this is the
befriend I get the most asked about I
have the clearest path to this uh
I'm not telling anybody but it's super
fun
I didn't know about everything about me
friends I don't know what this character
is yet
another epic you're gonna die flywoo
nice one we see it for the second time
today the fly a classic classic classic
character that is so entrenched in my
all-time content very fun stuff
this that one is for Marie Paul this
upcoming one is for Chris order 73.97
hologram one of one okay here we go one
of one who's this for
his name is Chris Chris if you're a
Chris who entered this there may be
multiple crisps order order 73.97 so
they could 73.97 You're Gonna Want to Go
full name here we go
oh there's a Gekko
the hollow gecko nice one all right rips
correct me if I'm wrong if we're gonna
get a monster card like an auto or
something or metal gunmetal like it'll
be the next card right it should be yes
or we're back to cores where we can find
the black cat but yeah we're back to
course okay so that means we're looking
for top characters rare robot black cat
I love it the Irish Terror a lot of
garyvee signatures on that I love it
black cat how many do we have left one
or two
there are
two left come on black cat
this one right here is for the Marlene
the next one coming up is for panda
radical the rabbit oh the hair excuse me
Supple wear hair
all right last card
for our friend Juan
and the Possum's always trolling me the
profound Possum's always trolling me the
profound possum was on the floor forever
and makes me want to I don't know I'm
not gonna go all right that was
phenomenal let's recap
recap I'm gonna grab some of our biggest
ones
we've got one of one's a lot of out of
twos which are pretty hard to find
alert aprara is a big one shout out to
cam with the Epic rhino
the auto the bubble gum bulldog
Diamond this is a lot of really nice
hits which is great because it's a break
and so you prefer to get a lot of really
nice ones yep
the biggest hit
the Curious crane autograph who got that
one
I do not want to backtrack and try and
figure this out okay you do your thing
yeah even bigger than that one again
stop it
um a lot of really cool hits so rips
we're gonna we're gonna case these up
and we're gonna ship them Insurance to
International correct yep okay and
everybody has their uh
addressed and we'll triple confirm the
address with email and all that yes sir
I love it congrats to all 30 winners I
hope everybody had a great time
um I uh I really really really enjoy
this please please please join the
Discord uh Whitney I'm glad you did you
can learn a lot about web3 the future of
nfts not nft projects nfts right nft
projects are like beanie babies or My
Little Ponies nfts or like stuffed
animals it is a macro more importantly I
continue to build this intellectual
property books video games cards and a
lot of you are destined to build your
own intellectual property so hopefully
through watching what I'm doing maybe
can help you
um learn what to do garyvee.com Discord
course so please share the links where
you can hope everyone I hope this was a
nice little break from uh
um your day and I'll see you all on
Discord for the last five minutes rips
thank you so much thank you g cheers
take care everyone